[موسيقى]
في بيئه عربيه تفيض بالاصاله والعراقه في
سوريا نشا ضيفي وتشكل وعيه بين نهر
الخابور في الحسكه والفرات في دير الزور
لينطلق منهما نحو العمل السياسي دون ان
يتخلى عن جذوره الراسخه عميقا في الباديه
الشاميه
دكتور رياض حجاب ما تاثير بيئه الشداده
عليك في فتره النشاه انا والدي موظف في
حقول النفط البس لذلك التحق ن به مندير
الزور باتجاه الشدادي هي بلده صغيره تقع
على ضفاف نهر الخابور لذلك يعني منذ
المرحله الابتدائيه انا قضيتها في بلده
الشدادي ثم تابعت المرحله الاعداديه في
نفس البلده واضطرينا انه نترك الثانويه
الشداده نتيجه عدم وجود مدرسين
ل الصف الثالث ثانوي العلمي فانا وبعض
زملائي اتجهنا باتجاه محافظه دير الزوره
ذكرت بان والدك كان يعمل بشركه للنفط ما
تاثير الوالد عليك في بناء شخصيتك
والوالده كذلك الحقيقه والدي شخص الله
يرحمه شخصيته قويه كان كادح ربى عائله
كبيره احنا عش اخوه ثمان شباب وبنتين
الوالد كان حازم وشديد كلامه نافذ له هيبه
الحقيقه اثر بي كثير كثير والدي والدتي
الحقيقه هي مدرسه بالصبر والحنان والعطاء
عانت كثير مع والدي خلال هذه الفتره كانت
محبه موده علمتنا صله الارحام كثير فلذلك
الله يرحمهم تركوا انطباع كبير بنفسي
وبنفس اخوتي كلهم ما الذي تعنيه دير الزور
الدكتور رياض حجاب دير الزور باهلها اللي
يتصفون بالطيبه تمسكهم بالعادات والتقاليد
والاصاله والمروءه دير الزور تعلمت فيها
الكثير فيها توليت المسؤوليه وفيها تعلمت
العمل واكتسبت خبره كبيره جدا وانا اعتز
باني ابن هذه المحافظه دير الزور كانت
دائما محطه فاصله في حياتك وهي التي يعني
اكملت فيها تعليمك الثانوي من هناك بدات
تهتم بالشان السياسي دعني اقول انت بعمر
صغير جدا التحقت بحزب البعث وعمرك 14 عاما
يعني ما الذي
يدفع شعب للانتساب الى حزب بشكل طبيعي كل
الجيل في سوريا عندما يدخل المرحله
الابتدائيه ينتسب الى طلايع البعث اللي تم
انشائها بعد عام السين ومن ثم الى شبيبه
الثوره لذلك يعني ما هو ما هو اخذ البعد
الفكري او الاديولوجي بقدر ما هو يعني
السعي الى انه يعني يكون في مجال للحركه
والنشاط والتفاعل لذلك انا في عندما بلغت
سن الثام عشر كنت عضو عامل في الحزب يعني
في الثالث ثانوي شاركت في انتخابات
المؤتمر القطري الثامن كان في نشاط في
المرحله الاعداديه في المرحله الثانويه
انا خضعت لكثير من الدورات
التاهيل العقائدي طبعت التدريب العسكري
كنت رئيسا للاتحاد الوطني لطلبه سوريا
لمده 10 سنوات عندما نقول دكتور الاتحاد
الطلابي نفهم ان هناك تيارات طلابيه وكتل
سياسيه هل حقا كانت سوريا في
ذلك الوقت تعدديه ام ان هذا مجرد يعني شيء
شكلي او صوري لا كان في احزاب للجبهه
الوطنيه التقدميه ممثله يعني حتى في
الاتحاد الوطني طلبه سوريا هم ممثلين سواء
كان في قياده الاتحاد في دمشق او في
المحافظات في محافظه دير الزور لم يكن لدي
ممثلين عن احزاب الجبهه كان في
مستقلين بالاضافه انه كان في الوسط
الطلابي في احزاب خارج احزاب الجبهه
الوطنيه التقدميه اللي يعني راسها حزب
البعث وهي احزاب يعني ممنوعه من النشاط
سواء كان في الوسط الطلابي او في الحياه
السوريه ومع ذلك كان في خاصه بال
اليساريين كان موجود ضمن الجامعه وكنا
نسمع اصواتهم في في المؤتمرات طلابيه وكان
لهم يعني حضور في كليه الزراعه في في دير
[موسيقى]
الزور تدرج حجاب في تقلد المسؤوليات من
الحزب الى السلطه في وقت شهدت فيه سوريا
انتقالا للحكم بيد ان السلطه المطلقه لم
تغير من طبيعه الرجل بقي قريبا من هموم
الناس بعيدا عن التسط حازما في مكافحه
الفساد
تقدمت في حزب البعث حتى اصبحت قياديا في
الحزب وتحديدا في عام 2000 دكتور انتقلت
السلطه من الاب حافظ الاسد الى الابن بشار
الاسد غير الدستور واصبحت الجمهوريه
وراثيه في تلك اللحظه كيف نظرت الى العهد
الجديد بصراحه شاهدنا فرق كبير ما
بين يعني حافظ الاسد وبشار بشار انا
التقيت به في عام ال 94 في اول لقاء كان
بيني وبينه بعد وفاه الباسل ب اسبوع
استقبلنا في بيت والده في القرداحه كنا
مجموعه من قياده الاتحاد
و رؤساء روع الاتحاد الوطني طلبه سوريا في
في المحافظات وانا كنت من ضمنهم كان موجود
هو وكان موجود اخوه ماهر انا يعني تولد
لدي انطباع انه يعني هو كان مرتبك مصاب
بالصدمه ما قدومه من بريطانيا بشكل مفاجئ
انه يحل محل اخوه باسل اللي توفى وبالتالي
كان الامر يعني يشكل بل الصدمه بالنسبه له
لذلك انا شاهدته يعني متلعثم في الكلام
مرتبك ما كان مقنع في حديثه بالنسبه لنا
عكس والده حافظ لم يكن مقنع يعني هل تعني
انه لم يكن مهيئا لذلك المنصب لا لم يكن
مهيا بشار في ذلك الوقت يعني عندما انا
التقيته في اول مره في عام ال 94 هو لم
يكن مهي على
[موسيقى]
اطلاق دكتور لو عدنا بالتسلسل الزمني
وتحديدا الى عام 2 وثلاثه ما بعد ال 2000
كان هناك حدث مهم جدا في المنطقه وهو غزو
العراق كانت دير الزور وانت ابن المنطقه
مسرحا ل مسرحا امنيا لعبور المقاتلين
بحكم منصبك وبحكم اطلاعك هل فعلا كان
النظام حينها غافلا عن تلك الحقيقه ام
متغافلا
عنها النظام كان يشعر يعني بخوف شديد
نتيجه ما يحصل بالعراق بانه سينعكس على
سوريا ممكن القوات الامريكيه يعني تتابع
من العراق باتجاه سوريا فلذلك كان يعني
يدافع بشتى الوسائل لذلك فت المجال للدخول
الى
العراق من جنب المعبر من
الساتر على مراه من الاجهزه الامنيه كان
يدخل الشباب من منطقه الباغوز كانت
الاجهزه الامنيه تسهل دخول المقاتلين
ياتوا من الدول العربيه وغير العربيه فهذا
يعني كان كله يتم بعلم الاجهزه الامنيه
وكل شخص يعني قبل ما يدخل يكون اجره عليه
دراسه كامله وعرفوا كل تفاصيل حياته
النظام في ذلك الحين كان يخشى من التوتر
الحاصل بالعراق لكن على منحى اخر كان ايضا
يخشى من التحرك الداخلي على على الصعيد
المحلي والغريب انه في عام 2005 تم تنظيم
مؤتمر من قبل المعارضه
و قمت انت بالموافقه على
ا حدوثه نعم لماذا المعارضه اجتمعت في
قريه محي ميده في في دير الزور وكان
الحضور بحدود شخصيه واحنا سمحنا بهذا
الشيء بعد دراسه هذا الامر بشكل معمق
باللجنه الامنيه بان بصفه امين فر حزب
ورئيس لجنه امنيه فنتي الضغوط اللي كانت
تمارس على سوريا في تلك الفتره انا خاطبت
بهذا المقترح القياده سواء القياده
القطريه او مكتب الامن القومي وبالتاكيد
هم تواصلوا مع القصر فجت الموافقه على
مقترحنا بانه يتم عقد هذا اللقاء ولكن
للاسف يعني فيما بعد يعني تم مسائلته
لماذا سمحتم بعقد مثل هذا اللقاء انا وجهه
نظري السماح بمثل يعني هذه التجمعات مثل
هذا عقد هذه اللقاءات افضل من انه احنا
نثير يعني الضجيج بمنع مثل مثل هذه
اللقاءات تبع هذا المؤتمر بعامين عام 2007
زياره تاريخيه لبشار الاسد لمنطقه دير
الزور التي لم يزرها حافظ الاسد ابدا ما
سر هذه الزياره لبشار الاسد حافظ الاسد
كان لديه انطباع انه محافظه دير الزور
قريبه من العراق ولديها ميل باتجاه العراق
لذلك هو لم يزر محافظه دير الزور على
الاطلاق بل عانت من الاهمال الشديد في عهد
حافظ الاسد في عام
2007 بشار الاسد يعني هي اول زياره له
كرئيس الى محافظه دير نزور كان الهدف في
ذلك الوقت اول تجديد للبيعه لبشار الاسد
الوضع في في المحافظه كان مغلق كان في
هناك احداث في محافظه الحسكه في القامشلي
وبالتالي يعني مجيء بشار كان هو رساله
للداخل وللخارج انه هو يعني موجود هو قوي
له قبول كبير ب من من كل ابناء سوريا وبمن
فيهم ابناء محافظه دير الزور علما بانه هو
زار دير الزور في عام ال 97 ضمن فعاليات
مهرجان الوفاء
للباس في عام 2008 كنت محافظا للقنطره او
الجولان والملاحظ ان عملك كمحافظ ل
اللاذقيه كان اكثر فعاليه وحضورا ما السبب
دكتور حقيقه عملي ما اختلف في محافظه
القنيطره عن محافظه اللاذقيه القنيطره
محافظه مهمه جدا وى حساسيه كونها يعني هي
ثلثين مساحه المحافظه محتل العمل في
محافظه القنيطره كان عمل سياسي واداري
بنفس الوقت يعني ما في وفد على يزور سوريا
ماني الا يزور محافظه القنيطره ونحن نشرح
للزائرين عن ما قام فيه العدو الصهيوني
بتجاه ابناء المحافظه انا بذلت جهد كبير
جدا في القنيطره حتى اذكر باول لقاء مع
بشار الاسد بعد اداء القسم تحدثت مع بشار
وقالت له انا بدي انقل كل دوائر او مؤسسات
الدوله الى ارض المحافظه فايد الفكره بشكل
كبير و واعطاني موافقه بالفعل انا قمت
خلال ست اشهر بنقل كل دوائر الدوله الى
ارض المحافظه تفاجات بانه صدر مرسوم
تكليفي محافظ اللادقيه وفور توليك هذا
المنصب مباشره قمت بتهديد مسؤولين
لا موضوع المحاسبه انا كنت اقوم فيه حتى
في في محافظه القنيطره المقصر بالتاكيد
يتحاسب والمثابر بعمله ويقوم بواجبه
بالتاكيد يعني يستحق انه يتكافل ماذا عن
الشخصيات المحسوبه او المقربه من النظام
هل كان هناك خط احمر ما تقدر تحاسبها ما
في شي اسمه خط احمر يعني طالما في خطا
وضمن الانظمه والقوانين ما في خط احمر
يعني اذا كان القصد انه والله في اللاذقيه
مثلا ال الاسد او مثلا اخوال الرئيس مثلا
ال مخلوف او ال شاليش او كذا انا ما
واجهني هذا الشيء وبالتاكيد هذول يعني
موضوع محاسبتهم يحتاج الى موافقه الرئيس
او ال القصر الجمهوري يعني انا خلال فتره
وجودي باللاذقيه ما هي فتره قصيره تم
اعفاء كثير من المدراء الدوائر مثل مدير
الزراعه مدير التربيه مدير المصال
العقاريه مدير الاوقاف مدير
التموين ح
وش سمعت هالشباب يما الحريه على الباب
يما طلعوا
يهتفوا بينما كانت سوريا تتارجح بين
الهتاف والرصاص حاول رياض حجاب البحث عن
طريق للخلاص الا ان حسابات السلطه لم تتفق
مع اطروحاته لحل الازمه فعقد الرجل العزم
على الخروج من دائره الحكم حتى لو كلفه
الامر حياته في الوقت الذي كنت تحارب فيه
الفساد في اللاذقيه كانت درعه تسير على
خطه الربيع العربي في ذلك الحين كيف كنت
تنظر الى الحراك في 25 اذار في في
اللاذقيه كان يوم جمعه انا كنت بجوله
ميدانيه للتحضير لزياره بشار الاسد الى
اللاذقيه اتصل معي امين فرع حزب الدكتور
محسن الخير وخبرني انه خرجت مظاهره ومتجهه
باتجاه ساحه الشيخ ظاهر في وسط اللاذقيه
وانا في الطريق لانه ها المظاهره رح تمر
من امام منزلي احنا وجهنا المشايخ انه
يذهبوا ويتحدثوا مع المتظاهرين للاسف كان
هناك في اطلاق نار وكان في قتله في ذلك
اليوم وكان يوم مؤسف الحقيقه الى الان انا
بصراحه ما اعرف من هو اللي اطلق النار
لانه يعني كل الجهات المعنيه انكرت انه هي
اطلقت نار انا اقصد الجهات الامنيه لانه
التعليمات كانت واضحه انه ما حدا يطلق نار
توسعت موضوع المظاهرات بعد موضوع القتل
وكان في هناك اعتصام في حي صليبه الشعارات
اللي كانت مرفوعه في في هذه التظاهر
الاولى ما كانت طالب باسقاط النظام ا ولا
يعني اسقاط بشار الاسد وصل الغليان الى
معقل النظام في اللاذقيه اللافت في
مظاهرات الصليبه انك شاركت بشكل مباشر
وقررت النزول الى الشارع هل نزلت الى
الشارع من تلقاء نفسك او احدهم او ربما
النظام طلب من ذلك لم يكن هناك توجيهات
اتخذت قرار باني انزل الى مكان الاعتصام
رغم معارضه اللجنه الامنيه بالكامل وترجون
انه انا ما اذهب الى مكان الاعتصام خوف
على حياتي لانه ما ما في يعني ضبط بالنسبه
للامور وخاصه انه يعني حصل يعني باكثر من
يوم عمليات
قتل حتى المشايخ اللي موجودين طلبوا مني
انه ما اذهب الى حي صليبه ولكن انا صغيت
وطلع معي على المكان الاعتصام قائد
المنطقه الساحليه واخذت قائد الشرطه وطلب
قائد الشرطه العسكريه انه يذهب معنا فعلا
ذهبنا الى حي صليبه كان الحضور بالالاف
حاولت اني اتحدث مع الموجودين كان الامر
صعب لانه الاعداد كبيره جدا
ف صعدت الى شرفه منزل ضمن الحاره اللي
مكان ضمن الشارع اللي موجود في الاعتصام
وتحدثت مع
الاخوه المعتصمين وسمعت منهم شو طلباتهم
يعني كان مطالبهم اطلاق راح
معتقلين قلت لهم اذا يعني موجود 100 معتقل
قبل الساعه ت انا ساوافيكم باسماء
المعتقلين اللي رح يخرجوا وبالفعل يعني تم
هذا الشيء طلبوا قانون الطوارئ بانه يلغى
وانا جاوبتهم انه يعني الدوله تحدثت عن
هذا الموضوع بانه تلغي قانون الطوارئ
تحدثوا عن مطلبهم بانه ما يكون في شبيح
وبالتاكيد انا مع هذا المطلب
طلبوا انه يكون في فرص عمل وانا وعدتهم
قلت لهم قدموا والكم وعد مني 500 فرصه عمل
وانا نفذت هذا ال المطلب كانت جميعها
مطالب مشروعه من يعني هي مطالب حقيقه
مشروعه اللي حصل ارباك في نهايه اللقاء
طلب بعض الشباب اللي موجودين في الاعتصام
انه محاسبه قائد الشرطه العسكريه اللي
موجود معي انه هو عناصره هم اللي قتلوا
اطلقوا نار فانا قلت لهم يعني اذا عندكم
اثبات قدموا لنا اياه حتى يتم يعني
محاسبتهم الحقيقه هون صار في ارباك
فالشباب اللي اللي دعوني الى حضور
الاعتصام نصحوني وترجون انه انا اغادر
لمكان وبالفعل انا غادرت كنت محكوما
بالامل لكن بشار الاسد كان يرفض الحوار
لماذا بشار الاسد فتح باب الحوار والتقى
مع وفود من كل المحافظات ومن كل الاحياء
ولكن المشكله والنقطه المحوريه اللي كانت
هي اساس المشكله انه هو كان يسمع ولكن لا
ينفذ شيء من الطلبات المواطنين لو كان في
استجابه لطلبات المواطنين ما وصلنا
الى يعني ما وصلنا
اليه في خدام هذه الاحداث جاء قرار مفصلي
وهو قرار تعيينك في وزاره الزراعه هذه
الحقيبه جعلتك اقرب واقرب من الشارع
السوري بعكس بقيه المسؤولين الذين كلما
ارتفعوا في المناصب كلما ابتعدوا عن
الشارع كيف اثرت عليك هذه الفتره دكتور
انا كنت اشعر من واجبي انه
اخفف عن من معاناه الاخوه الفلاحين الاخوه
مربي الثروه الحيوانيه لانه الظرف كان صعب
جدا وكنت اتوقع انه الحكومه اللي تشكلت
يكون فيها استنفار وانه تكون قريبه من
الناس تحاول انه تساعد الناس وتخفف من
معاناتهم تحاول انه تسد اماكن الخلل
والتقصير ولكن اللي لاحظته انه يعني
الحكومه منكفئ فبتالي انا بادرت من عندي
كوزير زراعه وانا وجدت في الوزاره يعني
اموال لم تصرف يعني كل هذه الاموال انا
خلال فتره وجودي بالوزاره باقل من سنه
ونصف ساعدت حوالي 18000 عائله من خلال
يعني انشاء مشاريع صغيره مختلفه تم تشكيل
وزاره جديده كنت انت رئيسا للوزراء فيها
ما الذي دفع ببشار الاسد ل تعيينك وكيف
وثق فيك
لتراس طاقم وزرائه اولا انا توليت مهام
عديده يعني خلال تراس بشار لرئاسه
الجمهوريه من فرع الحزب الى محافظ
القنيطره الى محافظ اللاذقيه ومن ثم وزاره
الزراعه الحقيقه انا ما كان عندي رغبه في
هذا الظرف اللي تمر به
سوريه يعني وزاره الزراعه عملي خدمي اساعد
الناس اما رئاسه الحكومه يعني وضع مختلف
كليا وانا ما بدي اكون ما بدي اكون شريك
في ما يحصل ففكرت اني اعتذر وانا بالطريق
اجاني تليفون ونصحني انه انا ما ارفض
والحقيقه وقت التقيت مع بشار جلسنا وقت
طويل انا ويا اكثر من ساعه ونصف اكثر
حوالي الساعتين وقال لي انه هو يعني معجب
بعملي سواء كان في المحافظات اللي شغلتها
او في امانه فرع الحزب او او في وزاره
الزراعه وهو يرغب انه انا اتولى هذه
المهمه براس الحكومه حكينا مطولا وانا
حكيت كل شيء
بنفسي ووضحت لبشار انه النهج اللي يتم
التعامل فيه مع المظاهرات مع الناس غير
صحيح وبالتالي احنا لازم يكون دورنا نكسب
الناس نكسب مواطنينا هذا التحدي بالنسبه
لنا مو التحدي انه احنا نخسر الناس استمع
باصغير وهو وافقني على كل اللي انا طرحت
له اياه كيف وافقك على كل ما قلته وثاني
يوم من تشكيل حكومتك وجه لك رساله دمويه
عندما تم قصف ر الزور الحقيقه كانت
المفاجاه قبل تشكيل الحكومه بعد اداء
القسم مباشره فاجات ببشار يقول انه هي
حكومه حرب انا اندهشت حقيقه من هذا الكلام
بعد تشكيل الحكومه تم قصف دير الزور وهذا
الامر ازعجني كثير مثل ما ازعجني القصف كل
المحافظات السوريه ما كان الامر يتعلق فقط
في في دير الزور انا يعني بيومها ارسلت
على وزير الدفاع وارسلت على رئيس الاركان
وسالتهم قالوا لي ما عندنا علم منو اعطى
الامر شلت التلفون وحكيت مع بشار فامر
مباشره باقاله قائد الفرقه العسكريه
وبعدين انا يعني استفهمت من وزير الدفاع
ومن رئيس الاركان قاد الفرقه ما له علاقه
كان يعطى الامر للقاده الميدانيين مباشره
مهما كانت ترتبهم تصدر من من اللجنه
الموجوده في القصر الجمهوري ورئيس الاركان
ووزير الدفاع ما عندهم علم بشيء من كان
يؤثر على بشار الاسد في ذلك الوقت يعني
اذا كنتم انتم اقرب الناس له كان مستمع
جيد ويتفق معكم تخرجوا من الاجتماع تجد
نتائج اخرى بشار حوله المجموعه سواء كان
اخوه او ابناء خاله او المقربين منه
بالاجهزه الامنيه او الايرانيين اللي
كانوا موجودين في كثير من الاحيان وقت
يصير نقاش يقول انا ما عندي علم وهذا
الكلام غير صحيح بشار كل شيء كان يتم هو
بامره وبموافقته وبتوجيه
منه ماذا عن انفجار خليه الازمه الضخم
دكتور كان هناك صوت داخل البعث يقول يجب
وقف الحل الامني من انصار هذا التوجه وكيف
تعامل الاسد اصلا مع هكذا توجه هذه الخليه
عقدت اجتماعها في ذلك اليوم في
مبنى مكتب الامن القومي وحصل
انفجار و قتل على اثره مباشره العماد حسن
تركماني والعماد داوود راجح شوكات ورئيس
مكتب الامن
القومي اللواء هشام اختيار النظام له
الدور الاكبر في هذه الحادثه وكان الهدف
الاساس هو عاصف شوكت لانه بشار وماهر
كانوا يتخوف من عاصف شوكات حتى بدي اذكر
انه بيوم الجنازه انتظرنا بشار وكانت كل
الترتيبات متخذ انه هو يشارك
لكن تواصلنا معه رفض انه يشارك بعد مقتل
اعضاء خليه الازمه دعوني للقاء في القياده
القطريه وكان فاروق الشر الامين قطر مساعد
واعضاء القياده وكان موجود رئيس مجلس
الشعب وبدا الحديث الاستاد فاروق
الشرع ويعني تحدث مع بشار انه يعني احنا
ما ممكن يعني نساوم عليك انت كمنصب رئسه
جمهوريه ولكن لازم يلتقى حل فخلينا نتواصل
مع اصدقائنا
انه يشوفونا حل بالتواصل مع بقيه الاطراف
نعمل اصلاحات بشار انفعل وانزعج كثير من
هذا الكلام حاول البعض انه يوضح هذه
المساله بشار زاد انفعاله بشكل اكبر وقال
انه انا بالنسبه الي ها معركه ولا بد من
الانتصار فيها بعد ما يعني انتهى الاجتماع
قال لي لا تروح خليك وقال لي انه
فاروق يعني صابه الخرف والمرض اثر عليه
وبالتالي من هون لشهر من الزمان راح يتم
اعفاؤه من من مهمته كنائب او ذكر لي ايضا
انه راح يتم حل القياده
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
القطريه
هل كانت هذه اللحظات بالنسبه لك لحظات
حاسمه هل بدات تفكر بينك وبين نفسك انه
حان وقت
الانشقاق الابتعاد عن
المشهد جديا انا فكرت بالانشقاق بعد ما
وصف الحكومه اللي انا شكلتها بحكومه
حرب الدماء في الشوارع
تسيل
والاعتقالات والتنكيل والفظائع تركتك بحق
الشعب السوري استخدم الدبابات
والطيران اول ما بدات استخدامه في حلب
الحقيقه كل هذا انا ما كان يخليني انام
على
اطلاق يعني انا مهمتي صحح رئيس حكومه
وماني صاحب قرار عسكري ولا اتدخل في
القضايا العسكريه ولكن انا ما يعني كنت
احس بمسؤوليه كبيره جدا وما بدي اكون شريك
بدم السوريين ولا بدي اكون شريك في في
دمار سوريا فهذا اول تفكير باتجاه
الانشقاق هل تواصلت معي اطراف داخليه او
خارجيه اخبرتها بهذه الافكار التي تدور في
راسك الانشقاق وترتيبات الانشقاق اطلاقا
انا لم اتواصل مع اي جهه خارجيه وانا احب
اكد على لهذا الموضوع لانه للاسف
الاتهامات كثيره كانت بهذا الاتجاه خاصه
من طرف النظام واذناب النظام انا لم
اتواصل مع اي طراف خارجيه ولا مع اي اطراف
داخليه على الاطلاق يعني اول شخص تحدثت
معه حول موضوع انه انا مفكر بالانشقاق هو
زوجتي اللي الحقيقه بدون اي تردد شجعتني
بشكل كبير جدا وقفت معي وايدت ني بتجاه
موضوع الانشقاق وهنا اريد ان اعرف دكتور
كيف تمكنت من تجاوز الحواجز الامنيه
التابعه للنظام ويعني ضعني بتفاصيل
تلك
المرحله ترتيب الخروج انه خلال ثلاث ساعات
نغادر من المنزل الى نوصل الحدود الاردنيه
وكان الاتفاق انه انا اخرج قبل الافطار
كانت يعني شهر رمضان في ذلك الوقت اخوتي
واخواتي كلهم هم وعوائلهم كلهم غادروا
باتجاه درعا بقي واحد من اخوتي فقط اللي
بيته قريب من المنطقه اللي انا ساكنها بال
المزع فنزلت انا وزوجتي واولادي وقت وصلت
لهناك بيت اخوي كان في سيارات ثانيه
موجوده امام البيت طلعنا فيها وذهبنا الى
بساتين كفر سوس منطقه الليوان تفاجات انه
وقت وصلت لهناك يقولوا لي انه ما في
امكانيه اليوم نغادر باتجاه درعا لانه في
تجديد امني كبير يعني ما راح نوصل الحدود
الاردنيه وكان هذا بالنسبه لي
صدمه حاولنا كثير بعدين قالوا زوجتي
واولادي يغادروا طبعا اولادي عرفوا انه
احنا يعني راح نغادر سوريا في تلك اللحظه
وكانت يعني صدمه بالنسبه لهم هم كانوا
صغار كان منظر يعني ما ممكن انساه منظر
زوجتي واولادي وهم يتركوني احنا ما نعرف
راح نعيش ولا نموت وللموت اقرب
لانه انا راح اشوف اولادي وزوجتي او اهلي
او ما عاد اشوفهم يعني كان منظر والموقف
صعب جدا
للغايه بالفعل احنا غادرنا غادرت زوجتي
واولادي وبعدهم انا غادرت كل الموجودين
يعني من الفصيل ما حدا يعرفني منه انا الا
شخص واحد فقط اخ ابو
عباده ترتيب على اساس اني انا ارتب الطريق
عن طريق جنوب سوريا بحكم الاقرب
هوش فانا بدات اني ارتب بعض الطريق على
اساس ان خلال اربع ساعات اصل الى
الحدود لكن طبعا واجهتنا صعوبات كبيره
بحكم وجود العسكري الكبير للنظام في
ذلك ووجود حواجز امنيه كبيره وجود قطع
عسكريه كبيره فاخذ مننا الطريق اربع ايام
اوثلاث ايام ثلاث ايام بالضبط
اخذ طبعا انا قسمت عائله
الدكتور
اقسام حتى لا قدر الله حصل شيء انه ما
تكون خساره كبيره
اي طبعا لما
جاء الكتور رياض معي لم يكن احد من الفريق
معي يعلم من معي يعني على اساس انه ضابط
منشط طبعا هذه السريه هي التي بعد الله عز
وجل جتنا الى انصل فاجانا باول من خروجنا
من دمشق انه يعني في حاجز عسكري انا بجنبي
سلاح اخوي نفس الشيء معه سلاح والشباب
اللي معنا كلهم مسلحين كان يعني القرار
متخذ هو
الاشتباك سبحان الله هذا الحاجز سمح لنا
بال بالمرور بدون انه يسالنا او يفتش هي
السيارات فشروا لنا انه امشوا انا كنت اظن
انه يعني الشباب اللي معنا هم مرتبين
الموضوع بعدين تفاجات انه يعني رحمه رب
العالمين هي اللي خدمتنا بالفعل ذهبنا الى
منطقه بريف دمشق قريبه هي منطقه الزاكيه
قينا للفجر بعد الفجر غادرنا
باتجاه كناكر ومن ثم كفر شمس ووصلنا الى
يعني مساء الى منطقه الل جاتنا ان نبيت في
اكثر من قر اول شيء بتنا
فيش ثم بدلت السيارات بشكل كامل بديت
انطلقت ودخلت وراح ورا قريه قريه كانت
هناك زوجتي واولادي واخوتي واخواتي هم
كانوا فاقدين الامل بالنسبه اسي وكان
التلفزيون السوري يبث انه انا تم اقالته
هذاك اليوم حاولنا انه نغادر سوريا ما
تمكنا لانه كان في تجديد امني كبير كان في
قصف على المنطقه صباحا جابوا عدد من
السيارات
للتمويه
ونقلنا الى قريه نصيب طبعا و وصلت على
نصيب اتصلت بمقدم ياسر العبود الله يرح
كان هو قائد فصي في اخبرت انه الدكتور رض
والدكتور رياض والعائله موجودين في ارجو
انك ترطب مع الاخوه
الدخ مساء وقت متاخر بتسهيلات من الجيش
الحر خرجنا باتجاه الحدود سوريا الاردنيه
وهناك دخلنا الى
الاردن ليست الارض السوريه وحدها من تشظت
جراء الحرب
[موسيقى]
المدمره الانسان السوري ايضا تشتت في
تغريبه طويله حتى تقاذفته
الامواج وعلى الضفه الاخرى تفرقت المعارضه
السوريه في دروب متباينه في رؤاها ورؤيتها
لواقع
الحال
[موسيقى]
وفي مسار مواز للثوره كان ثمه مسارات اخرى
جهود دوليه لحل سلمي لم يرى النور
ومفاوضات لم تعقد حول وطن يتشظى في اتون
الصراع بعد الانشقاق دكتور ووصولك الى
الاردن كيف تعاملت معك المعارضه ا للاسف
ما حدا تواصل معي من المعارضه السوريه
بالعكس وانا حتى داخل سوريا قبل ما اوصل
للاردن كنت اسمع يعني تصريحات المعارضه
السوريه انه بدهم يحاسبوني على الفتره
اللي خدمت فيها الدوله وانا ما اعرف يعني
ليش بدهم يحاسبوني مفروض هم يعملوا على
كسب اكبر قدر ممكن من المسؤولين اللي
موجودين في النظام السوري وبالتالي عدوهم
عن هذا النظام ولكن مثل هذا التعامل يعني
ترك انطباع سيء وبالتالي ما عاد في شقاق
لماذا لا نقول دكتور ربما انهم كانوا
حذرين لانك كنت اعلى مسؤول ينشق عن النظام
سمعت من هذا الكلام يعني كان البعض يشكك
وحكاها في وجهي وللاسف يعني حتى من فترات
قريبه يعني اسمع مثل هذا الكلام تمثيليه
من النظام للاسف انه هي التمثيليه من
النظام وبشار الاسد يريد يختر المعارضه من
خلال انشقاقي انا للاسف يعني بعد عشر
سنوات اسمع هذا الكلام وهذا شيء مؤلم
بالنسبه الي انا ولعائلتي ايضا لانه هذا
تشويه للسمعه
النظام يقول انه واذناب النظام يقولوا انه
خرجت من اجل يعني الحصول على مبلغ مالي
للاسف يعني انا كنت رئيس وزراء على راس
مهمتي كيف اخرج من اجل مبلغ
مالي يعني اذا كنت بحاجه المال او بدي مال
ما كان انا موجود يعني المال في في موقعي
انا رئيس حكومه ومن المعارضه اللي يشكك
ويقول انه بشار الاسد يعني بعثني حتى
اخترق صفوف المعارضه صفوف المعارضه مخترقه
يعني بشار نفسه كان يتحدث يعني في
الاجتماع اللي عقدناه بالقصر الجمهوري حكى
بالحرف الواحد قال طالما هذه المعارضه
موجوده انا مطمئن موجود على كرسي الحكم
انا اقصد المعارضه التقليديه المعارضه
الرسميه ولا اقصد اللي خرجوا في المظاهرات
من الشباب السوري في الداخل دكتور كان لك
جهود ومبادرات بعد انشقاق قمت بالتواصل مع
عدد من القيادات
والدول والمؤسسات الدوليه حدثنا عن هذا
المسار وهل كان كان فرديا ام كان منظما
انا بشكل شخصي زرت العديد من الدول دول
عربيه ودول اقليميه زرت دول اوروبيه
التقيت مع المسؤولين مع قاده عرب استمعت
من الجميع وهذا شكل عنده رؤيه واضحه وضح
لي كثير من الامور اللي انا ما كنت يعني
مطلع عليها ايضا من خلال لقاءاتي مع هؤلاء
القاده سمعت منهم قلقهم من وضع المعارضه
السوريه وضعف ادائها وعدهم خشيه بانه اذا
انهار النظام هذه المعارضه غير قادره
لاداره الدوله السوريه البعض ايضا دكتور
كان يقول بان خذن المجتمع الدولي للشعب
السوري يعود الى انقسام المعارضه وعدم
وحدتها انت ماذا تقول المعارضه السوريه
تتحمل مسؤوليه تتحمل مسؤوليه كبيره لانها
معارضه اولا ليس لديها رؤيه سياسيه وهذا
انا اللي وجدته بعد ما خرجت ليس لديها
مؤسسات
حقيقيه معارضه مشرمه في حاله فوضى ا للاسف
تخضع ل المحاصصات
وتقاسم النفوذ والمصالح ولكن هذا يعني لا
يعني انه المعارضه السوريه هي تتحمل فقط
التبعات المجتمع الدولي تعامل بتراخي
بالقضيه السوريه ودعم الشعب السوري صحيح
تم تقديم دعم للمعارضه سياسي واعلامي
واقتصادي وعسكري ولكن كان في تراخي وعلى
راس هؤلاء اصدقاء الشعب السوري الولايات
المتحده
الامريكيه والامم المتحده التي كانت عاجزه
عن تنفيذ قراراتها التي كانت عبره على ورق
للاسف كل القرارات الاموميه اللي صدرت لم
ينفذ من ه شيء بالاضافه
ل يعني اصدقاء الشعب السوري قسم منهم كان
يعني يعمل على احتواء المعارضه بشتى ال
السبل
ويدعم بقاء النظام السوري اتخذت الهيئه
العليا ووفد المفاوض قرارا امس
وابلغته للسيد د مستوره باننا اخذنا قرار
بتاجيل مشاركتنا في المفاوضات في العام
2015 تشكلت الهيئه العليا للمفاوضات
وانتخبت منسقا عاما لها قيل انها تشكلت
بايعاز امريكي هل هذا صحيح الهيئه العليا
للمفاوضات تم تشكيلها بعد اجتماعات فينا
المجموعه الدوليه لدعم الشعب السوري او
لدعم سوريا اللي اسها هذه المجموعه كانت
بحضور الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وروسيا
فخرجوا بجمله من المقررات من ضمنها توسيع
المعارضه السوريه من خلال انشاء هيئه تقوم
على التفاوض تم الاتفاق على عقد هذا هذا
اللقاء في المملكه العربيه السعوديه بدعوه
طيف واسع من المعارضه السوريه نتج من عن
هذا المؤتمر تشكيل الهيئه العليا
للمفاوضات اللي تقود العمليه السياسيه و
هي تشكل وفد مفاوض يتولى هذه المهمه لكنك
استقلت ايضا من الهيئه العليا للمفاوضات
نعم انا استقلت بعد حوالي سنتين
اي انا تم انتخابي منسق اي عام للهيئه
العليا للمفاوضات انا كنت ارفض انه يتم
تسميتي رئيس هيئه لماذا استقلت كان عليك
ضغوط دوليه للاستقاله لا ليس هناك ضغوط
دوليه ولا اقليميه انا استقلت لانه
الحقيقه كان هناك تماهي من الام المتحده
والمبعوث الاممي مع الموقف الروسي وكان
يعني دوما يطالبوا بتنازلات وكان في سعي
انه لتغيير مقررات مؤتمر رياض واحد اللي
طالب بانشاء هيئ حكم انتقالي الطالب بانه
يكون في محاسبه يكون في عداله انتقاليه
وللاسف يعني اطراف المعارضه وافقت على هذا
الشيء وعلى راسهم الائتلاف لذلك انا يعني
ما ممكن اقبل بهذا الشيء هل يمكن لما يسمى
اعاده تهيل النظام ان يكون حلا او مدخلا
لحل سياسي النظام يفهم هذا الموضوع بالعكس
ويعني مسؤولين و حكوه بشكل واضح هو يعني
يعتقد بانه يعني المجتمع الدولي وال
الجامعه العربيه بعدت عنه وبالتالي هم
مضطرين الان بعد ما يعني يعتبر حاله انتصر
بعد ما انتصر على الشعب السوري هم يعودوا
له هو لم ينتصر على الشعب السوري هذا
النظام مجرم فقط
صلاحيته فقط شرعيته وبالتالي كل يعني ما
يطرح باعاده تاهيل النظام هذا النظام غير
قابل
للتاهيل لا تلتئم الجراح والبلاد على
[موسيقى]
حالها الحرب تستعر الديار اطلال والمقابر
بالجمله وشه اللاجئين يتمدد خارج حدود
الوطن ورغم ذلك يتمسك حجاب بامل لا يزول
ان تشرق شمس سوريا ولو بعد
حين اليوم بعد مضي عقد على الثوره سوريا
الى اين دكتور الحقيقه الواقع السوري صعب
جدا
ومؤلم سوريا اليوم في خمس جيوش على
ارضها اليوم سوريا فيها اربع حكومات حكومه
النظام وحكومه قسد وحكومه الحكومه المؤقته
تتبع للائتلاف وحكومه الانقاذ تتبع هيئه
تحرير الشام الوضع السوري ماساوي ومعاناه
سوريين كبيره في كل مكان لذلك الحقيقه هذا
الواقع مؤلم جدا هناك انهيار اقتصادي هناك
تفكك في مؤسسات
الدوله هناك معاناه للسوريين الموجودين
في في المخيمات معاناه كبيره جدا شخصيه
مثل الرياضي حجاب ان شقط على النظام هذا
مكسب كبير بعتبره
[موسيقى]
لان كان دوره عند النظام قوي جدا ونحن
بتتمنى هدور هذا ينفذ ههم في الارض
[موسيقى]
المحرره يضاف الى كل هذه المعاناه الفاج
الكبرى الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب سوريا
وتركيا يوم الاثنين 6 شباط والحقيقه هالنا
تلكؤ منظمات الامم المتحده والمجتمع
الدولي في مد يد العون للشعب السوري في
شمال غرب سوريا انترك وحيدا ايام عديده
دون تقديم اي عون او مساعده للفرق الدفاع
المدني التي باشرت بانقاذ وال الحقيقه هذا
ما ادى الى مضاعفه حجم الخسائر للمنكوبين
من جراء هذا الزلزال الحقيقه هذا التقصير
الذي حصل اثناء هذه الكارثه والفاجره
الكبرى ترك اثر كبير في نفوس
[موسيقى]
السوريين
والحقيقه هذا يعني واقع ماساوي نامل من
الله رب العالمين انه تكون المرحله
القادمه افضل باتجاه انفراج وايجاد حل
للماسه السوريه ما هي بوادر الحلول دكتور
يعني كيف ممكن اعاده ضبط البوصله من اجل
اتفاق في اطار وطني شامل هناك تحولات
كبيره الان تحصل في العالم وهناك ايضا
تحولات في المشهد
السوري في في المنطقه ككل وخاصه بعد الحرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا وانكفاء القوات
الروسيه من من سوريا هنا هناك محاولات
التوسع في النفوذ الايراني
واخذ مكان القوات اللي تغادر من روسيا
هناك تصعيد اسرائيلي باتجاه الوجود
الايراني في سوريا كل هذا الحراك ممكن
بتقديري انه يعمل شيء خلال المرحله
القادمه نتمنى انه الملف السوري لا يبقى
كما تسعى كثير من القوه الى ابقاءه على
وضعه الحالي نتمنى يتحرك هذا الملف اتمنى
انه يكون هناك تحريك لتطبيق القرارات
الامميه وانفاذ وان يكون هناك انتقال
سياسي كيف يمكن ايجاد حلول وانتم لا ترضون
الا
ب التنازل تنازل الاسد عن كرسيه وهو متمسك
في هذا
الكرسي لا يمكن ان يكون هناك حل بوجود
بشار الاسد بشار الاسد اللي دمر سوريا
وقتل مئات الالاف من السوريين وشرد م
ملايين السوريين الان الموجودين في اكثر
من 100 دوله حول العالم هؤلاء السوريين
اللي هجرهم بشار الاسد هم تقريبا نصف
الشعب السوري فكيف ممكن يكون حل بوجود هذا
النظام المجرم القاتل لذلك لا يستقيم حل
اذا ما كان هناك في عداله انتقاليه ولا
يعني هذه التضحيات اللي قدمها السوريين
ستذهب سد لذلك لا يمكن ان يكون حل ان يكون
هناك حل بوجود بشار الاسد الا تعتقد بانه
هذا الطلب مستحيل في ظل الواقع المعاش
وتمسكه بالسلطه كل هذه السنوات دتور ما في
شيء مستحيل امام اراده الشعب هذا الشعب
اللي قدم كل هذه التضحيات بالتاكيد لن
يقبل ب بوجود بشار الاسد فبالتالي لن
تستقيم الامور ولا يمكن ان يكون هناك
استقرار في سوريا وفي المنطقه بوجود بشار
الاسد على سده
[موسيقى]
الحكم ما مش شك دكتور باننا جميعا نشعر
باننا جزء من هذا النسيج الاجتماعي في في
قطر لكن يبقى الانسان يحن الى الوطن في
الغربه مهما كان سريع الاندماج في محيطه
تحن سوريا اكيد بالتاكيد
بالتاكيد يعني الحلين الوطن موجود بشكل
دائم والحقيقه انا يعني وقتي اقضيه في سفر
لا ينقطع وهم لا
ينفرج احمل القضيه السوريه معي بكل مكان
سواء كان هنا في الدوحه او في كل مكان
اسافر عليه هذا همي
الاول بالاضافه انه يعني مساله التواصل
مع السوريين انا احاول التواصل بشكل دائم
مع مع الجميع وهذا يعني عمل يومي بالنسبه
الي ا نعمل على صعيد السياسي
الدبلوماسي القانوني من خلال المنظمات
اللي يعني نعمل من خلالها وهذا على حساب
بالتاكيد عائلتي انا نعرف تماما انه مساله
الانشقاق والقرار اللي اتخذته له تكاليف
باهظه
و انا واسرتي ندفع هذا
الثمن ثمن الانشقاق واحنا مستعدين وانا
لست نادم على الاطلاق لذلك يعني احنا
عندنا وضع خاص نتيجه هذا الشيء ونقدر هذه
الخصوصيه دكتور من اجلهم واجل حمايتهم
وامنهم وسلامتهم اليوم اكثر من نصف سوريين
في الشتات نعم وكما يقال ما اضيق العيش
لولا فسحه الامل سؤال الاخير لك هل ما زال
للامل متسع الامل كبير بالله عز وجل قبل
كل شيء ومن ثم بهمه الشباب السوري الصاعد
الذي غير الموازين في المنطقه واقول
للاخوه السوريين يجب ان لا نقلق من مسائل
اعاده تاهيل النظام هذا النظام نظام مجرم
فقد شرعيته وفقد
صلاحيته لذلك يجب
ان نعلم انه هذا الذي يحصل هو مخاض مؤلم
لولاده عقبه جديده تختلف عن
سابقاتها علينا ان نتحلى بالصبر
والامل وان لا ننتف كثير
للخلف علينا ان ننظر للمستقبل ونعد العده
لمرحله القادمه ان شاء الله
واحنا املنا بشعبنا بحفاظ على وحده سوريا
بالحفاظ على النسيج الاجتماعي السوري لانه
لا يمكن ان نعيش كسوريين الا مع بعض حتى
نعمر بلدنا ونعيدها افضل ما كانت ونخلص من
هذا الظلام الجاثم على صدر السوريين عشرات
السنين احيانا تمضي بنا الحياه الى مسارات
لم نخطط
[موسيقى]
لها لكننا نحتاج لاختيار الزاويه المضيئه
والسير
نحوها طريقي مع رياض حجاب انتهى لكنني
ساكمل الطريقه مترقبه لقاء شخص اخر مع
جانب اخر
[موسيقى]
جديد
ه